good morning John I really like
backstages yesterday which is today
actually we played or are about to play
depending on how you look at it at the
mcglue in theater possibly it's in
Charlotte North Carolina
it's a beautiful theater it has a dome
it has like red carpet everywhere
there's stained glass windows upon
arriving at a venue the thing I want to
see first is the backstage I want to see
how weird and different it is and I want
to try to understand how it works a
little bit even though like when you
actually get to a backstage you realize
the glamour isn't isn't really there
like you think about backstage is like a
place where only a few people get to go
there's backstage passes and that has a
very specific connotation but like it's
usually dingy and gross and like there's
you know like utility sinks but every
venue is kind of the same from the front
like of course it's very different going
from like a beautiful room like this to
like a middle school auditorium but it's
just a stage with a bunch of chairs when
it comes down to it the layout of the
backstage is always completely different
right get them aglow and we walk down
three flights of stairs before we got
like to the green room and like
backstage at VidCon I mean it looks and
smells like a high school cafeteria
there's sort of two reactions you can
have to a backstage you can get back
there and be like oh this is you know
the glamour is gone I now understand
that this is just a rare and indeed kind
of a less good room than Bell the
front-facing parts of event but then
there's the other way to look at it
which is the kind of all the things that
make the world actually work tend to be
hidden from us they're above the drop
ceiling they're behind the scenes under
the hood all of the pipes and wires and
servers and ducts we have this instinct
to hide them so that we can like create
a nice shiny glossy beautiful thing that
may it's like all the things that we
actually there's a lot that goes into
our hidden so that we can make it look
like magic being able to see and start
to understand the magic I think that's a
big reason why I love backstages
because they don't have drop ceilings
they're like hey just we're not gonna
pay to make this advance I'm obsessed
with this stuff like if you watch my old
tour
from last year oh man I got my flippin
to some places I've tried to get myself
into the places here I failed
unfortunately wires room 204
no Hanks gotta go in there
it's locked no-nothing does the secret
room is locked oh look at that weird
dirt oh that would have been cool the
other dressing-room also has a secret
door with a less creepy way to get to it
it's also locked probably probably I
love little doors any door that is not
the size of a full-height man is like
the fit like I don't know what it is it
gives me very intrigued I think
sometimes we're too good at hiding the
hard work that goes into making things
function but like I love beautiful
design I love beautiful things but I
also want that magic to be stripped away
a little bit so that we can appreciate
the beauty of the function like a car
engine is that's beautiful as a car and
a CPU is as beautiful as a phone and a
backstage is as beautiful as a stage
John I'll see you when I see you John
it's been really fun to hang out the
tour bus is amazing though I have
identified a problem with it yeah I
don't know how does this happen but they
are there they're just everywhere